All right, let's get started. So today
we're going to continue our discussion
about MPC. In particular, we're going to
wrap up our discussion about persistent
physibility as one of the key properties
we want to imbue in our MPC control
pipeline and then we switch to the topic
of uh stability. So not only we want to
make sure that the MPC loop has a
feasible solution at each point in time
but we also want to make sure that
whatever action we optimize for does
something useful in our problem setting.
Useful means we are stabilizing uh the
system that is converting to zero. We'll
then wrap up the discussion with a
couple of uh um
uh topics that are practical elements
specifically how some of the
optimization could actually be computed
offline as opposed to online. That was
actually a pretty big deal about 10
years ago where hardware was not
particularly advanced yet and
optimization solvers were not
particularly advanced yet. So offloading
part of the optimization offline was a
big deal because it relieved what you
had to do online. So basically it
minimized delays. And then we're going
to talk about uh the application of MPC
to a slightly more general setting which
is that of a trajectory tracking. And uh
I will show you how the NPC formulation
has to be modified a little bit to
ensure that you have a good tracking
performance. Interestingly enough,
sometimes people in industry gets gets
it wrong. So I want to make sure that
you are not one of those people. Uh all
right. So last time we introduced the
concept of MPC. It's a bit dark here.
Let's leave it at this before the entire
setup explodes. So um we talked about uh
MPC introduced the concept. I introduced
a specific problem setup
uh which is that of controlling a linear
time balance system such subject to
polyhedral constraints. We talked about
uh the problem uh persistent physibility
and stability. We introduce some uh
concepts in particular the concept of a
onestep controllable set the concept of
a control environment set the concept of
a positive environment set the concept
of a physibility set and then we state
the lema which reads as if set x1 which
is essentially traned physibility set
where we look at uh uh uh feasible state
control pairs starting from stage one as
opposed to zero. Well, if this set X1 is
a control variant set for the system
under consideration, then the MPC low is
persistently feasible, which means that
at each dependent cycle, you have at
least one feasible solution. As I
mentioned last time, this result per se
is not particularly useful because X1 is
not one of the tuning knobs that you can
manipulate in order to tune your MPC.
But we see is a stepping stone for the
theorem that I'm going to state in a few
minutes that actually relates the
concept of resist persistent physibility
to one of our tuning knobs that is
actually the terminal set itself that we
uh use as one of the constraints in our
MPC formulation.
With that context, let's prove this uh
physibility lema. The proof is not
particularly
um you know interesting but at least it
stress tests your understanding of uh
some of the concepts we have uh
discussed uh so far. So remember that we
want to show that sorry uh if x1 is a
control environment set then the MPC low
is persistently feasible. So once we
transition to the new state from the
perspective of the new state x1 we still
have a control that is feasible over the
optimization horizon. So the proof is as
follows.
Remember the definition of a onestep
controllable set.
So the onestep controllable set to x1 or
previous of x1 is defined as the set of
states. This is just a definition that
we stated last time is define a set of
states in Rn such that there exist a
control a physible controls such that ax
plus bu transitions into the set x1. So
that's a definition of a onestep control
uh set. Now since X1 is a controlling
variant
again by definition of controlling
variance for all states within X1 there
exist a physible control such that ax
plus BU is in X1.
Now if we
compare the two definitions we see that
uh x1
a point that is in x1 also belongs to
the previous of x1 to the one step
controllable set is the same property
but the point that is in x1 also has to
be in capital x by the definition of x1.
X1.
X1 is first of all the set of states
that are physible. So that are in X.
Which means
that the set X1 has to be a subset of
the intersection between a set X, this
is trivial, and the pre the previous of
X1. Does it make sense? is a bit of a
mouthful but uh it just follows from the
definitions. Now
let's go back one step and now reason in
terms of set x of zero. So this is the
set of uh states x of0 such that there
is a sequence of controls such that the
states generated under the dynamics are
produce states that are
physible.
Remember my definition of X0. X0 is the
set of physible states such that there
is exist there exist a sequence of
controls physible controls
such that under the
uh dynamics evolution the generated
states are also physible and satisfy the
terminal condition. Now I can rewrite
the definition of X0 as
the set of feasible states such that
there is a physible control such that X1
belongs to capital X1 because capital X1
subsumes
uh where is the definition capital X1
previous slide
the fact that there is a truncated
sequence of controls that lead to a
feasible state trajectory
Uh
okay.
Now again let's compare
this definition to the definition here.
So they are identical. The only
difference is that in here I'm imposing
these additional constraints that the
states has to belong to X. So x0 is
really the intersection of capital x and
the onestep controllable set to x1.
But then we put together the two facts
and we see that x1 is a subset of x0.
Every state that belongs to x1 is also a
state that belongs to x0. Does this make
sense? It's mostly basically pattern
matching the different uh definitions.
There is no particular cleverness here.
Yes. So
it's not necessarily
>> no because of uh how we define it here
is any state that transition us into X1
could also be a state that is not
feasible in terms of set membership to
capital X.
Okay. So
now there is the slightly more
interesting part. Actually this entire
proof is quite boring. Uh take some
state that belongs to x of zero some
initial state
and let u star zero be the solution to
the finite time optimization problem.
MPC optimization problem. Let us start
zero being the first control in this
sequence. Then under the control u star
zero under the MPC control we transition
into a new state x1
since you start zero is clearly physible
x1 belongs to capital x1 because it's
part of the MPC trajectory. So by
definition has to satisfy all the state
constraints under the dynamics evolution
and so it belongs to x1.
But we just prove that set x1 is a
subset of x0 which mean that set x1
belong actually to
set x0 which means that the new
optimization problem is indeed feasible
and then you can recursively apply this
property through time.
So rewinding all of this, we wanted to
prove that under the MPC control law,
the new [clears throat] state X of one
X1 belongs to X0, the set of feasible
states for MPC. to do so we manipulated
a little bit the definition of a
one-step controllable set and the notion
of um control and violence and we
finally proved
that
if set x1 is controlling violent then
the problem is persistently feasible.
Does it make sense? Again, not a
particularly exciting result, not also
particularly useful, but it's a good
stress test for you to see whether you
um you know understand the notion of a
one step controllable set, control
environment set and so on. In the final
exam, there will be one question that
will where I will ask you what is say
control environment set.
Okay. Anyway, so
so say that the horizon is equal to one
then um we can just choose the terminal
set to be controlling violence and by
the previous lema we know that if that
is the case then uh the MPC problem is
feasible at all planning uh stages
But of course in general the
optimization horizon is greater than
one. So how can we extend these results
to the cases whereby we have a general
optimization horizon capital M. So
that's what we're going to do next.
Any questions in the meantime?
So [snorts] now we get to the more
interesting part.
So building on the lema that I just
showed that says that if X1 is
controlling variant then the MPC control
law is persistently feasible. Now we can
prove a more powerful theorem that reads
as follows. If the set X of F which is a
reminder is the set through which we
specify a terminal constraint for the
MPC optimization problem. This is
something that we decide and if set x of
f is a control environment set for the
system under under study then the mpc
low is persistently feasible
that's interesting uh let's try to
understand what is saying what is a
trivial control environment set for this
system meaning a set that if you are
there there exist a control that allows
you to stay
Well, any mathematical equation if you
are in doubt always say zero. I mean
typically zero is the best guess in this
case is correct. So the origin zero is
indeed the control environment set. If
your state is x equals 0
uh assuming that u equals 0 is an
allowable control which is typically
true. I mean doing nothing is typically
allowed
under linear dynamics. If you are at
zero and you use control zero, your next
state is zero. Which means that the
origin you have a set with only one
point but still is a set. The origin is
indeed a control environment set. And
intuitively what is it saying?
It's saying that if we just target the
origin in n steps and then I shrink the
horizon by one there is always um an
admissible control sequence that is the
concatenation of the previous control
sequence and then the fact that with the
last control would just stay at zero. So
you can just trivally continue your
control sequence to have a full and step
control sequence. So we're going to
prove the theorem but intuition is quite
obvious.
That said
for a general system you might have a
different control environment set. Zero
is just an option but actually you could
have a larger set which is a control
variance for the system. We'll see later
uh how to compute those larger sets. So
do you think that the origin is always
the best choice?
So constraining your system to reach the
origin in end step as part of your MPC
control law. You think that this is
always a smart thing to do. It
guarantees you persistent physibility.
So that's great.
Remember that typically
you are not just reasoning in terms of
controlling the state to zero but you
also want to be very parsimmonious in
terms of how much control you spend. So
often times asking your system to reach
the origin in n steps as part of your
MPC optimization problem can be very
limiting. So basically you are asking so
of all the control sequences you could
apply you're only optimizing over those
that in end step to the origin typically
those that require a lot of control
effort. So yes, you have persistent
physibility but now you might control
your system very suboptimally meaning
with a lot of control uh expenditure. So
that's why in general the terminal con
constraint that is something that you
artificially add to your MPC problem to
ensure persistent physibility should be
as relaxed as possible so that you don't
overly constrain your system. Does it
make sense?
just trying to give you both
mathematical
um backing for what I'm saying but also
some practical considerations
and this stuff that people do for for
real right so it's it's constantly you
know a little bit of a design choice how
to probably set x of s so now let's
prove this um theorem
so the proof is as follows
so we prove that if x of f is
controlling violent. Then x n minus one
the truncated set where your horizon is
only one is also going to be controlling
violent. And then if xnus one is
controlling variant xnus 2 is
controlling variant all the way to x1
and once we hit x1 we know from the
previous lema that if x1 is controlling
variant then the system is persistently
physible. So we can invoke that lema to
conclude the proof of the theorem.
So let's start with the first step. So
if XF we want to prove that if XF is
controlling violent XN minus one is
controlling Vant 2. X N minus one is
defined as usual now is is just a
truncated physibility set where we only
reason in terms of a onestep horizon is
a set of states physible states for
which there exist a physible control
such that under the system dynamics we
have a sequence of states that is
feasible in this case um the last state
needs to satisfy the terminal sl.
Now
um because of the terminal constraint
we know that
um remember that we want to show that
this uh set is controlled environment.
So the question is for any state
so any vector within this state is there
a control input that allow us to
transition back into this set under the
system dynamics.
So that's what we want to prove. Now
what we know is that uh by the
definition of xn minus one
um
there is a control such that a x
a x nus one plus b1 is equal to xn which
belong to the terminal set x of f. I
mean this is by essentially definition
of x1.
Now the question is
does XN which belongs to XF also belong
to X1? If that is true that it means
that X1 is controlling environment. I
found actually a control that allows me
to transition back into X1.
But for now the only thing that I know
is that X of N belongs to XF.
But from the assumption theorem we do
know that x is a controlling varant set
which means that there exist a u such
that ax plus b belong to x of f [snorts]
but is indeed the definition of uh that
defines the membership of a point to xn
minus one. So we have just proved that
XN minus that XN indeed belongs to
capital set XN minus one. Don't be mixed
up with the subscript
X Xnus one is just a definition of a set
is the one step physible set. So the
fact that Xn belongs to XUS one doesn't
tells you nothing in terms of the
temporal coherency between the
subscripts.
So we have just proven that x of n
belongs to capital x n minus one. So we
have just proved that x - one is indeed
controlling environment. But then you
can apply this argument recursively
until to prove that x -2 is controlling
environment. X - 3 is controlling
violent all the way to x1. At the point
we invoke the physibility dilemma from
the previous lecture and then we can
state the claim that if XF is
controlling violent then MPC is perally
feasible.
Does this make sense?
Again is a bit of pattern matching with
definitions. [snorts]
Most important thing for you to
understand is and this is a big deal. If
the set XF is
chosen to be a controlling vent set for
your dynamics then your set your MPC is
perically feasible. Now the origin is in
general u a control environment set. So
is a possible choice for your terminal
constraint in general is a bit
suboptimal. So we want to have more
sophisticated choices for the terminal
set within all the possible ways of
defining a controller and set. We'll get
back um we'll get back to this point
later along with a pointer to um
computational tool that allows you to
compute control environment sets. And in
problem set three, you'll have a few
problems that will uh um expose you to
how to use this uh toolbox in order to
comput
control environment sets.
I mean this is my son that brings back
uh bugs from child care. This is sort of
bio the child is sort of biological
weapon. This is my 445. I mean I'm
recording so I don't stop here. So we're
just complaining about the diseases that
go around in the cher anyway. So the
terminal set X of F is introduced
artificially for the sole purpose of
leading to sufficient condition for
persistent physibility is one of the
tuning knobs. And now we know that at
least from an abstract standpoint if we
choose X of F to be controlled by set
persistent physibility is guaranteed.
As I said, the simplest choice would be
to just pick X of F as the origin, but
this is generally undesirable because it
excessively restrict the space of
feasible control sequences. We'll
discuss this choice uh later in more
detail. Now we switch to the other topic
that is that of stability.
Now we know at least how to make the
problem persistently feasible. The
tuning knob that at least for the scope
of this class we choose for that purpose
is the control the terminal constraints
X of F. We have other two tuning knobs.
How we select the terminal cost P in our
MPC formulation and how we select the
horizon N. So the question now is can we
tune those tuning knobs in such a way
that stability is guaranteed.
[snorts]
To prove stability, we will leverage the
tool of leapo stability that some of you
may already be familiar with, but if
you're not, no problem. I'll give you a
very quick intro to leapono uh
stability.
So what does the stability say? I will
uh state in a second the full theorem,
but first I want to give you intuition.
So say that you have a dynamical system
s
+ one equal f of x k or maybe in
continuous time you also have x dot
equal f of x.
Now the question is
is the system stable? Roughly speaking,
if you start close to an equilibrium
point, will you go back to that
equilibrium point uh without, you know,
having trajectories that go out of
whack?
If this is a ball,
this is a stable equilibrium point
because uh if you have a ball in the
ball, never got the pronunciation right,
but anyway. So this is a ball and this
is a ball and uh uh so if you have a
ball in a ball um you know that if you
start this ball outside of the
equilibrium point then it will start
oscillating and then if you have a
little bit of friction you dissipate
energy you will go back to the uh bottom
of the ball. So it's the case of a
stable equilibrium point. If you're
here,
of course, this is unstable. This is an
equivalent point. So if you put the ball
here, it will stay here. But then if you
start a little bit farther from the
equivalent point,
you will go down.
So say that you have a dynamical system
and say that you have an equivalent
point and you want to understand if the
dynamics are at least locally stable
around that equilibrium point.
How can you show that? Well, all that
you know is that you have an equilibrium
point and you add a transition dynamics.
So in principle, what you will need to
do is to solve for all possible initial
conditions around your equilibrium point
your discrete time equation or
differential equation and then see what
happens. Now in general solving
nonlinear differential equation or also
discrete time nonlinear
update equations is complicated. So for
the longest time this was a big problem.
Then there was a guy leamp of that came
in and saying well maybe we can say
something about the stability of the
system without reasoning directly in
terms of the um evolution of the state.
The idea is if we can say that there is
some function that loosely speaking has
a notion of an energy function that
decreases over time
along the system trajectories that might
tell me could tell me something about
the evolution of the underlying system.
Think about energy being dissipating
along the evolution of a system. That
means that basically the system
inherently is constrained to reach a
point of minimum energy because you're
dissipating energy. So basically this
intuition is if I don't need to prove
that all the trajectory goes to zero. If
I can say tell to the system that the
system is dissipating energy then
probably will converge to some state of
minimum energy loosely speaking.
So that's basically what the leaponov
theorem says. Consider an equilibrium
point for a system xk + one equal of f
of x k. Equilibrium point means that if
you are at zero f of 0 is equal to zero
meaning that we stay there.
Let's consider a set omega which is
closed bounded and positively invariant
set. This is some mathematical thing
that we need not super important.
Let v
referred to it as the leapono function
be a function that has the following
property. Is it zero at the origin is a
positive outside of the origin.
And for the evolution of system
trajectories starting from omega then
this function decreases along the
trajectories.
then x=0 is asytoically uh stable.
So
essentially you have
[snorts]
um
this is your v function
v of x. This is a a two dimensional
state space.
If I can say
that along all possible system
trajectories
V decreases in value,
it means that the state trajectories is
going to the bottom which is the
equilibrium point since V 0 is equal to
zero
which again is including this notion
that uh you are trying to show that your
system is losing energy along ong the
system trajectory.
Note how with this theorem and that's
the most important thing we can claim uh
stability properties without having to
solve explicitly the uh state transition
equations or a system of differential
equations if you are in continuous time.
So that's a main thing about uh the
appro as long as we can find a function
with such a property then um so we can
argue about stability.
Now you might say how do I find such a
function B? I mean that's hard. That's
actually the hard part. So in some cases
u there are some um
uh physical arguments that allow you to
construct the upnot functions for
example energy arguments but in many
cases uh you can use other arguments and
this is the case that we will consider
for MPC now if you're interested in
theory it has a very le theory so I
would recommend to have a look at some
of the references that I provided For
the sake of this class, the only thing
that I want to say is that there is a
tool that allow us to infer stability
property for a closed loop system that
entails
uh using an auxiliary function referred
to as a diapon function and show that
under the system trajectories that the
function has a non-deereasing property
namely this property here. So what we're
going to do now to show stability is to
show that for the MPC the closed loop
MPC law we can find a leap of function
so that we can then claim stability for
the MPC control law.
So the question is what is this the
function
and here there is another theorem but is
the last one for MPC. So
any questions so far?
How many of you heard of leapono
stability before?
Half. Okay. Well, in any case, read
about it. It's a it's a useful and
interesting tool also with uh of course
I presented here quite uh quickly but
also with a rich um um
physical interpretation. Again,
main thing that I want to make sure you
understand is that uh it's essentially a
tool that you have to inferative
properties about dynamical system
without having to resort to explicit
integration of the underlying uh uh
system equations. It boils down to show
that for some choice that you had to
come up with of a function V, you have a
um a non-increasing property uh of the
function V. If you do that, then you can
infer stability. So we're going to you
use the leap theorem a little bit in a
mechanical way without spending
additional time in explaining its
origin. But I do encourage you to do a
little bit of reading on the opponent of
stability because it's an interesting
topic.
Okay. So let me state now the celebrated
stability theorem.
This is an interesting case whereby for
20 years or so people applied MPC
without any theory and then in the '9s
people started develop theory to more to
tune the algorithm in a more principal
way. Do you know something that is
happening right now with no theory?
Deep learning. I mean nobody knows
exactly why it works but people use it
all the time. Who knows maybe in 10
years there will be the analog of uh I
mean there is some theory behind deep
learning but it's typically uh for
settings that are not really uh
reflective of what people do in
practice.
So same here NPC for 20 years people
they applied it just worked well and
then people said no actually we can add
some theory and this is one of the
celebrated theorems within this theory
it says the following let's assume that
we are in a um
uh LQR type of setting so the cost is a
two normal cost so xrpose qx plus urpose
ru so we have a quadratic cost let's
assume that the control pen is positive
definite. We also assume that the states
penalty is positive definite and the
terminal penalty is positive definite.
We assume that the in sets xf and u
contain the origin in the close this you
know just to make the math be super
solid but it's not the most critical
assumption. Let's assume that xf is
[snorts] controlling violent. What do
you think we make this assumption
>> exactly? This is to to ensure that at
least NPC is feasible. So we got that
covered. And let's assume this fourth
assumption here that looks very weird.
So basically it's saying that the there
exist a u such that ax plus b u belongs
to the uh terminal set and such that
under this u cx u plus p of x vu minus p
of x is less than or equal to zero. And
this has to be true for all x in xf.
That's weird. Um but and and we'll see
how we use this result. But just to gain
a sort of intuition,
remember the leapon theorem that I
showed you before, we want to show that
along the trajectory something has to
become negative.
Here basically what we want to say is
that there exists a U such that C plus P
at the next state is less than uh or
actually let's put it this way P at the
next state minus P at the current state
is less than or equal to minus C and C
is a positive thing. So is a sort of
reminiscent of um
a leap of like condition
we'll see how we apply it. I just wanted
to give a little intuition about why
this way. I mean the first time that I
saw it as a student I said I mean where
is this coming from? It was like some
nightmare of a mathematician.
So if all of this is satisfied then the
um origin of the closed loop system is
asytoically stable with domain of
attraction x of zero. namely that your
MPC control law if started within
um
capital X0 is going to asynthetically
converge to the origin. So it works.
We'll see after I prove this theorem how
this actually leads to an action
actionable recipe to select the tuning
knobs for your MPC. meaning how to
select x of f how to pick uh p which is
your terminal cost but let's first prove
the theorem and the idea here is to come
up with a leapon function for the mpc
control law
and show that the diapon function is
indeed a leapon function. So you have
this decreasing property which allow us
to invoke the leapon uh theorem to claim
stability MPC control law. [snorts]
So the proof is as follows. I think this
proof is is proof is quite cute is is
more interesting than uh the persistent
physibility proofs that personally I do
not really like. All right. So
um as your colleague said because of
assumption A2 namely that the terminal
set is controlling violent then MPC is
guaranteed to be persistently feasible.
We already proved that. Okay.
Now what I want to show is that uh J
0* X
which is the optimal cost of the MPC
problem when initialized at X it's just
a function it maps X into a number
that function is indeed a leapono
function for valid function for the MPC
control Oh,
so that's our
if that is true then we can invoke the
leapono theorem and show stability.
So essentially what we're going to do
next is then go step by step through
leapono theorem show that all its
assumptions are verified most
importantly the uh the [clears throat]
decreasing property of a leapon function
for this very specific choice
and then invoke the leapon theorem to
claim stability.
So let's do it step by step. For first
of all
let's write uh
the closed loop dynamics
as x
what do we use there? Xt + one
equal f of closed loop of x of t.
Remember that f of closed loop of x of t
is um
f of x comma
the uh mpc
low. Once I write u as a function of x
through the MPC optimization, then I get
a system that is just a function of x.
Does it make sense? Once u is written as
a function of x, I can then write
everything as a function of x. That
function I just call it f close u. So
first of all, we have to be disciplined.
Is the origin
an equilibrium point
for the uh closed loop system. Closed
loop meaning once we use the MPC
controller as our control signal.
Well, what does it mean to be an
equilibrium point? It means that if you
are a state zero, I solve my NPC
problem. I get the optimal control and
then I transition into a new state that
is equal to zero.
Well, if I start at zero,
assuming that u equals 0 is a feasible
control and
remembering that our cost is a summation
of quadratic terms
where Q and R are positive definite.
What do you think the optimal um
sequence is that uh the MPC
is going to optimize for?
What is the result of NPC optimization
problem?
>> Zero
>> zero because the cost is greater than or
equal to zero and if you start at zero
and use equal equal to zero this all
this cost is going to be equal to zero.
So zero is a lower bound and there is
this actually u such that you achieve
zero. So that's the optimal uh control
sequence. But if you start at zero and
use control u equals z what is your next
control uh sorry your next state
zero because our dynamics are ax plus b.
So we just proved at the minimum that
the origin is an equilibrium point for
the closed loop system.
square then x0 is bounded and closed.
That's a bit of a mathematical thing not
important here. Now
what I want to claim is that the optimal
cost which is a legitimate function from
the state to uh the real numbers is
indeed a leapno function. So now we have
to show all of the different criteria
for J star to be a function meaning has
to be zero at the origin
has to be positive elsewhere and it has
to decrease along the system
trajectories. So let's start with the
easiest one.
So what is J 0 of zero? So if you're at
zero, we already shown that the optimal
solution is u equal 0 throughout the
horizon.
with corresponding cost equal to zero.
That's a easy one. Also quite easy to
show that if you start at a state x
different from zero then the cost is
going to be positive because remember
that your cost you start from
um k equals z you go to n minus one of x
k.
So you have at least the term x0
transpose q x0 since x0 is different
from zero and q is positive definite at
least the first term is going to be
positive which means that if you start
from a state that is different from zero
your optimal cost is positive. Okay
so to me that's the easy part of the
function. uh the harder part is to show
that along the system trajectories this
function is decreasing over time. So
basically you're dissipating energy
you're dissipating cost which means that
over time you'll get to the lower bound
which is your uh equilibrium.
How do I show that? So let's consider an
initial condition that is feasible
meaning that there exist a feasible uh
solution to the MPC problem.
Now the terminology here is a bit clumsy
[snorts]
but uh uh just follow me.
Let u subscript zero of superscript zero
being the um
uh optimal control sequence computed at
the first iteration of MPC iteration
zero
and let denote the corresponding state
trajectory as x of0 which was our
initial condition x10 x and zero and so
After we apply the first control in the
control sequence according to MPC, we
transition into a new state x1 that
according to our dynamics is simply a x0
plus b u0 superscript zero. So far no
surprises. Now let's see what happens
now that we have transition into step
one.
Let's consider uh a sequence of controls
obtained as follows. I take the tail of
the previous control sequence
and then I append a control V that is um
chosen to be a a physible control
and let's denote these corresponding
state trajectory the corresponding state
trajectory as X1 is the point we're
starting from look how the subsequent
states are essentially the states
that uh would have would have been
predicted from a perspective of uh the
first planning cycle
but starting from time 2 and the last
state is simply given by axn plus bb.
Do you see this? So this is the part
where terminology gets a little bit
mixed up. Not mixed up is gets a little
bit confused. So basically you have
So at the um
first computation cycle you have u 0 0
u1
uh zero dot dot dot dot u n0
and then u minus one
and then correspondingly you start from
state X of0 you go into state X10
dot dot dot dot dot X n - one uh xn
zero.
Okay. So now let's assume
that uh we transition into the new state
x1 equal to a of x 0 plus b
u 0 0
which means that basically you are
transitioning to this state here. So if
you now start applying
this state control sequence, you will
transition along the same states that
you predicted from the perspective of
the previous planning cycle. So that's
what I'm trying to say here. And the
last state, so the state that is one
time step after is axn plus bb. So
nothing particularly deep here, just a
little bit of bookkeeping in terms of
terminology. Any
questions here?
>> Yeah,
>> I guess we're going to this if like the
quadratic cost is collapse, right? Can't
we just argue that it's decreasing?
>> Well, we have to we have to show that it
decreases along the trajectories
generated by the
um closed loop system. So it's not
entirely obvious that uh when you
evaluate the cost along those
trajectories the cost necessarily is
going to decrease.
>> Yeah.
>> At least you wouldn't know a priority
that that is the case
>> calculated based off of your initial
state.
>> Yes. But then that final control that
you're implementing B is that
>> for now this is just a the only thing
that I'm saying is that it's physible Q.
Now we show that for a more
sophisticated choice of V I can find a
control sequence that allows me to tell
something about the decreasing
properties of the diap function. for now
it's just a dumb u um um you know
control sequence that I want to consider
on this note let's be a bit smarter
and let's we know that xn0 belongs to xf
this is the terminal constraint for the
mpc problem solved at step zero
since xf is controlling variant I know
that there exists the physible control
that allows me to transition back into
Excel. So now I'm refining the selection
of V into the selection of a specific V
that allows me to for ax plus BB to stay
in the um
uh control set
X of F.
That means that uh this control sequence
is now a feasible sequence for the MPC
problem starting at step one. Why?
because V satisfies the control
constraints and the state trajectory is
uh feasible in the sense that uh all of
the states
x to 0, x and0 are going to satisfies
the state constraints because of uh how
the trajectory of step zero was computed
and the terminal constraint is also
satisfied because I chosen V in such a
way that the final state
is in XF. So we satisfy the terminal
constraint. So all of this to say that
this specific choice of a control
sequence is a feasible
control sequence for the MPC problem a
step one.
So now what we're trying to see is
whether we can use this controlled
sequence to say something about the
evolution of the cost j0 along the
trajectory. So essentially we want to
say is
jar of x1 less than j star of x0. That's
what we're trying to get to the point
because if we can say that then we can
invoke the leap theorem. Now for now the
only thing that we can say is that the
jar zero of x1
is less than or equal to the uh cost
related to um applying this candidate
control sequence. Why less than or equal
to as opposed to equal? Because for now
all we know is that this is a feasible
controlled sequence but it's not
necessarily optimal. So the only thing
that we can say is that the optimal cost
is upper bounded by a cost of a physible
control sequence.
Okay.
Now let's add and subtract
couple of terms. So we add P of X and Z,
we subtract it. We add the C of X0 U 0
and we subtract it.
Look at these three terms.
in red. When you sum them, what do you
get?
Remember that uh uh
u0 sub ukerscript zero was the optimal
control sequence for the MPC problem
from the perspective of stage zero. So
when you sum those terms, what do you
get?
So here's a the summation of the stage
wise cost. This is a terminal cost. So
it looks like the cost of an optimal
control problem. Which one?
>> Exactly. Plus one
uh for your grade. Yes,
that's exactly right. So all of these
terms
really correspond to the uh optimal cost
because we're using the optimal control
sequence of MPC problem solved from the
perspective of step zero. So I can
substitute from that. So those three
terms are now encapsulated here and then
I have the remaining terms.
Now,
now we play the assumption three that
leapno like uh assumption
the assumption three says that for all
states in x of f there exist a control
let's call it u um uh v star with a
property that ax plus bv star is an x of
f that's what v star does
uh such that
um let's go back rewrite here in case
so we keep keep it here it will also be
useful later. So the minimum
over u
minimum over u in u such that ax plus b
u is an xf [snorts]
of
u minus px
plus c of x u plus p of ax + b uh
uh all of this is less than or equal to
zero for all x in xf. So that's
assumption three.
So now what I'm saying is that among all
those
upper bar that
allow me to transition into the
controlling set x of f. I pick the one
that minimizes this quantity. And I know
that the one that minimizes this
quantity has the property that P of ax
plus b bar minus uh p of
uh minus p of x [snorts]
plus c of x d bar. All of that stuff is
greater than or equal to zero.
So for that specific choice of
V upper bar, the three quantities in
blue sum up to something that is greater
that is less than or equal to zero,
which allows me to derive the key
inequality whereby Jar0 of X1 is less
than J star 0 of X0 minus this term
here,
you know. So basically I have J star
X0
is equal to is less than or equal to
oops sorry
the star of X1 is um
0 plus C um minus C of X0
Oh, sorry.
U 0 0
plus
a term
and I know that the term is less than or
equal to zero. So that implies that jar
x1 is less than just jar 0 x0 minus this
quantity here.
Does it make sense?
Since this term by assumption three I
know is less than or equal to zero.
Well, but c of x0 u0 is greater than
zero for all initial states that are not
the origin again because the cost is
positive
uh for all states that not equal to the
origin because of uh it's a quadratic
cost. So we have just shown
that the jar x1 is strictly less that
the jar x0 meaning that the cost is
indeed guaranteed to decrease along the
system trajectories. So then we can
invoke the leapon stability theory and
then claim that indeed the MPC control
law leads to closed loop dynamics that
are asatically stable. So are guaranteed
to converge to the origin assuming the
assumptions are verified with domain of
attraction uh x of z.
Any questions here?
I think that's an interesting proof.
It's actually quite powerful. So try to
go through it a few times just to
internalize it. This is a fairly
important proof.
Okay. So now we have a theorem that
allow us to reason in terms of
persistent physibility. a theorem that
stability. How do we make those theorems
actionable? Meaning how do we link those
theorems to specific selections for x of
f and the terminal cost which in our
case we're assuming the terminal cost is
quadratic. So we want to understand how
this what this theorem tells us in terms
of how we choose capital P
and we're going to see a couple of
settings. So the first setting is we're
given linear dynamics but now a is a
syntactically stable meaning that all
values of a lie in the within the unit
circle.
So let's define
XF as the maximally positive invariant
set for the system XT + 1 equal A XT.
How do you compute this positive
invarance set? I'll show you in a couple
of slides the link to a very handy
toolbox
to compute these sets numerically. So
you just use this math toolbox, write
down a couple of commands and you'll get
this set.
Now x of f as defined is a controlling
varant set since once you are uh in this
set since u equals 0 is a feasible set
then a of a of 0 is is zero. So you stay
there.
So the persistent physibility part is
relatively straightforward. Now how do
we prove how actually how do we use the
stability theorem? Remember what the
stability theorem is asking us?
Actually let me write it in terms of a
quadratic cost.
So minus xrpose px plus xrpose qx plus
uranspose ru
plus ax
+ b u transpose p a x + b u. So we want
this stuff to be greater than less than
or equal to zero for all x in xf.
So let's consider the specific control u
equal to zero.
The question is for this specific
control u is this inequality satisfied?
If that is the case, that's great. Then
we can um
uh infer stability. Now if you set u
equal to zero,
this term goes away. It's equal to zero.
This term goes away. This term goes
away. So essentially we are left with
the inequality minus xrpose px plus
xrpose qx
plus
xrpose arpose p a x less than or equal
to zero. It just so happens that this is
not a random matrix equation. It's
actually a very famous equation referred
to as the liapon equation. And it turns
out
that if Q is positive definite and I A
is a statically stable there exist a
positive definite P such that all this
quantity is equal to zero which
satisfies this condition here. So what
does that mean? That if you choose P as
the solution to the diapon equation and
you are guaranteed that such a solution
exists and it's positive definite so it
satisfy all our stability assumption
with that selection of P as a terminal
cost MPC is going to be
asynthetically stable.
So what's the intuition here? The
intuition here is that basically
uh you optimize MPC in such a way that
after n steps you end up
if you do nothing in uh afterwards into
this uh O infinity uh set and then you
will let your natural dynamics that are
stable to drive you to the origin. In
reality won't you won't do that because
by reoptimizing you're always going to
uh find some different control sequence
but basically that set serves as an
anchor to make sure that uh you know you
you uh you stay grounded into desirable
behavior
mechanically what do you do you call a
computational tool that I'm going to
mention in a second to compute such a
maximum positive invarian set and then
we choose a P in order to solve the
dapon equation is another oneline
command in MATLAB. You plug those
numbers into your NPC, you're guaranteed
persistent visibility and stability.
So what if [snorts]
um
a is not uh
stable meaning that your natural
dynamics don't help you with going to
the origin without control? Well, that
means that you have to do active control
in order to make sure that you go to the
origin. So in this case, you still have
a similar pro procedure in order to tune
your um
parameters, but you now use LQR, active
control as basically your uh controller
that allows you to anchor your future
dynamics into some dynamics that will
lead you to the origin. Specifically,
let f infinity be the optimal gain for
the infinite horizon lqr controller. set
x of f as the maximum positive vant set
with respect to the lqr
closed loop dynamics which means that uh
after n steps when you hit u um
set x of f if x of f if you do do if you
don't do any replanning at least you
have a physible controller that allows
you to uh stay within the set x of f but
then if you choose uh uh the terminal
cost P in such a way that uh your LQR
controller would essentially brings you
to the origin then you are guaranteed to
be uh stable. Now here the derivation is
a little bit more convoluted
algebraically so I'm not going to show
it but essentially the style of
reasoning would be the same. We plug the
controller the LQR controller U= F
infinity X into this inequality and then
we we will show that if we pick P as the
solution of this equation then we will
have equality. So we will satisfy the
stability [snorts]
uh condition and this equation again is
not a random equation. This is the
Ricati equation and is guaranteed to
have a solution. So bottom line if you
have unstable system you pick your uh
terminal set as the maximum positive
variant set for the uh closed loop QR
dynamics. You pick P as a solution to
the discrete time equation. You plug
those numbers into your NPC controller
and then you're guaranteed to have
persistent physibility and stability and
you have a couple of problems in your uh
pet. Now these are not necessarily the
best possible choices but just some
choices that are very procedural.
So if a is stable maximum positive
maximally positive invariant set with
respect to the uncontrol dynamics choose
p as a solution to the diapon equation.
If a is unstable, choose your terminal
set as the uh positive set for your uh
lqr loop dynamics and choose p as a
solution to the ricati
uh equation with um
with idea again that you basically carve
out a region x of f where the optimal
unconstrained controller is considered
to be feasible and this is used it as a
value function to guarantee stability.
All right, that was quite a bit. Uh, let
me conclude with the two very quick
things. So the first one is that so far
we've been looking at MPC through the
lens of online optimization. So measure
your state, you solve an optimization
problem online basically on your device.
Get a control sequence, you apply the
first control input and then you
reoptimize.
Now it turns out that there is also an
explicit slash offline version of MPC
that allow you to premputee NPC control
law such that you don't have to do any
optimization online
to appreciate that let's go back to our
usual setup by the way MPC can be
generalized also to nonlinear systems
but here you know the goal of this class
is to give a broad overview of different
control techniques. So we'll only
discuss it in the context of the linear
system. It is already quite interesting.
So we're back to I mean usual setup
linear dynamics quadratic cost. So it
turns out
that the solution to the constraint LQR
problem is a control which is a
continuous pie-wise ained function on a
polyhedral partition of the state space.
That is
there exist a partition of the state
space. So that if say in 1 2 3 4 five
regions such that if your uh initial
state for your MPC computation is here
you can just look at a lookup table and
then the optimal control policy is
simply f of x plus g where the fkj and
gkj are gains associated with the
specific region. So basically the
solution to LQR is just a peacewise
um
a fine control
um which allows you to basically do a
lookup table search online meaning that
you measure a state you'll see in which
region the state falls you pull out the
gains corresponding to that uh uh region
and then you have your optimal control
law There is no optimization that you
have to do online
and these terms f and g and the
partition of the state space is all
computed offline. I'm not telling you
how to do it. I'm just saying that this
can be done.
So you say great why don't you do it all
all the time. There's I mean this is
great for a number of reasons. Basically
it avoids you to solve an optimization
problem online. You know solving
optimization problem also has its own
challenges beyond just uh how quickly
the optimization problem can be solved.
For example, you have to show say that
you are in a safety critical situation.
You want to land the rocket on earth.
Well, it means that you really trust
your optimizer not to have bugs. So from
a a development program standpoint, it
has cost. You need to have additional
people. They have to write optimizer.
They had to customize it. They had to
code it into an embedded environment.
You had to validate it. Here everything
is explicit so the validation step is
much easier. On the other hand it turns
out that often times this poly inter
partition of the space takes very weird
shapes mean I mean meaning that you have
a lot of cells
and today the optimizers such as the
convas optimizers have become so good
that often times it's faster to just
solve optimization problem rather than
just doing a lookup table in a very in a
gigantic table. So explicit MPC
as a good concept for you to know with
understanding that often times you just
use online optimization these days.
So
we essentially dis uh discuss the famous
multi-step design process for MPC where
we choose uh you can also play a little
bit with horizon length. In this class,
we focus primarily on XF as your uh
tuning knob for persistent physibility.
So you tune XF to be control environment
so that you have persistent physibility.
You choose the parameters Q and R freely
to affect the control performance. You
adjust capital P as per the stability
theorem and then you have an automated
way to tune your MPC algorithm to
compute uh these you know control sets
and so on. is a very handy toolbox which
is MPT3 and that's what you will uh uh
work with in your pet 3.
Um
one last thing in the uh past four
minutes
so far we have looked at MPC as a tool
in order to uh achieve uh stability. So
basically you want to make sure that the
state converges to zero. But often times
you want to use NPC for for tracking. So
basically you're giving a reference
trajectory for example computed through
a direct method. And then you want to
use an MPC wrapper that basically allows
you to uh counterreact any disturbances
and make sure that your actual
trajectory stays close to the reference
trajectory.
So the most naive way of setting up the
tracking problem is to have a cost where
you penalize deviations from your
reference trajectory plus a quadratic uh
penalty for the control effort.
So this formulation does not work. The
reason why it doesn't work is that uh uh
often times to track a reference
trajectory you need zero control. So say
that you have an aircraft and you want
to track a a constant altitude profile,
you can't really switch off the engine.
You still need like a constant thrust.
So what happens if you use this
formulation is that the moment your um
tracking error goes to zero. [snorts]
Now the cost is dominated by your
control effort. So now MPC is trying to
minimize the control effort. So
basically you reduce thrust and then
your um tracking cost goes up. So you
start going to this kind of oscillations
in which in between control effort and
tracking error uh cost. So what's the
solution? You reframe the problem in
terms of delta control. So basically how
you change controls uh with respect to
time steps as opposed to absolute
control. So you frame the tracking
problem as a problem of minimizing
tracking error. So y is uh c of xx I
mean c could be also the d identity
could be just x k minus rk where r is
your reference plus a penalty term with
respect to the deviation control
variables where the delta us are defined
as a uk minus uk plus minus one so that
in perfect tracking what you have is a
zero tracking error and a custom control
meaning constant thrust which means
delta U equals Z which corresponds to
what MPC really wants to do in this
formulation.
So all this to say that this is a better
version of other considerations to take
into account for tracking. But just to
give you uh some intuition about how for
tracking you want to be a little bit
more sophisticated in how you set up NPC
problem. In particular typically you
want to use reason in terms of delta
controls. So the optimization variables
are the delta use that are defined as UK
minus ukus one. You are given the u at
the time t minus one and then you obtain
all the use recursively by um uh adding
the delta use that are really the
optimization variables. Does it make
sense?
All right. So we quite a bit. So this
lecture essentially wraps up the first
part of the class where we assume that
uh uh everything about the model is
known. Starting from next week, we'll go
into
um the new setting whereby the model may
not be completely known anymore. So
either you have to adapt to the part of
the model that is unknown or learn what
you do not know in order to still act
optimally or very close to uh optimally.
So P3 will be an interesting one. So it
will expose you to a lot of these uh MPC
ideas and will also uh force you to work
with the MP3 MP3
toolbox uh which is kind of neat. All
right. So see you next week.